hello guys i am back and you're watching
some sub a channel on how to survive in
the online jungle today i'm going to
attempt to answer a question that any
cyber security specialist has asked
himself more than once
why oh why does hacking look so stupid
in hollywood movies
[Music]
while having a budget of tens or even
hundreds of million dollars it doesn't
really figure that these guys can't
afford industry consultants right it's
either this or well fbi agents defuse
nuclear bombs using excel and tony stark
suit can be hacked with the use of code
from an online store and you know it's
not just cyber security consultants that
hollywood seems to be saving money on
check out jason bourne's passport in the
bourne identity now this russian name is
actually just a collection of random
letters as if someone has just spammed
their keyboard according to this
passport his name is asher flushtoshfum
you can't even pronounce it
anyway let's start with a small quiz
what was the name of the first film
about cyber criminals
one was it war games two sneakers
three was it hot millions or number four
was it hackers
let me know in the comments how you
responded
now the correct answer is sure to amaze
you as much as it amazed me
because it's hot millions
[Music]
the first ever cyber criminal appeared
on the screens in 1968 and the role of
the hacker was played by the charming
peter ustinov
who is well known to all moviegoers for
his role as hercules
[Music]
the main character is basically a
self-confident swindler or fraudster
who's trying to steal money from a large
insurance company to do this he gets a
job at the company under the guise of a
computer specialist now using internal
documentation the hacker breaks into the
system and makes insurance payments to
shell companies and the hacker used the
name of well long dead composers as
recipients beethoven visit gnu faust one
of the great men
but of course it's a dream and then he
repeats his scam but he gets quite techy
with this one instead of forging
documents he begins to change records in
the database itself however suspicious
payments are discovered by his colleague
and the self-confidence swindler has to
get out of there pretty quickly caesar
smith is a thief
cesar smith
well although this is the first
appearance of hackers on the screen it's
probably one of the most realistic
representations of real hacking the
system is hacked from the inside by an
employee of the company who has direct
access to the systems terminals
[Music]
how are you all right you'll see that
social engineering methods are used here
the hacker pretends to be another person
and uses colleagues to obtain important
information that he needs you know it's
quite curious really is this was the
first ever instance of hacking to be
carried out do you remember in the video
i think it was on digital identity we
told you that the first ever security
system was invented by fernando cabato
in 1962
the mit professor distributed usernames
and passwords as a way to basically
control how much time students were
spending on their computer the young
student alan sher didn't take a liking
to this so he basically wrote a program
that printed out all of the usernames
and passwords of the other students and
then used them to basically gain
infinite computer time pretty neat right
it's unlikely that the filmmakers of hot
millions knew about this but they
guessed the algorithm of future attacks
correctly these kinds of links still
happen all the time which is why you
should never use the same password for
two different devices but i think that's
clear by now if you have been using the
same password for everything or at least
for the majority of things check your
account through have i been porn or
breach alarm is another one you may have
an unpleasant surprise waiting for you
by the way the rapid detection of
hacking is definitely a thing nowadays
large sums and strange recipient names
don't go unnoticed the principle of
searching for abnormal behavior and
non-standard transactions is still very
relevant in financial for detection
systems you've probably encountered the
work of such algorithms if you ever
tried to make a large purchase somewhere
that's far away from your place's
residence or if you forgot to switch off
your vpn for instance banking systems
actually track the place of payment for
example if you use a card in cafes and
shops in manhattan a large purchase in a
boutique in dubai or hong kong will seem
suspicious and will then require
additional payment confirmation you know
the script of hot millions was highly
appreciated by critics actually in 1969
i think its authors among whom was peter
ostenov himself were actually nominated
for an oscar
anyway in 1973 the foresight of the
authors of the film was confirmed by an
unlucky new york clerk who tried to
steal 1.5 million dollars from the union
dime savings bank congratulations you're
a prophet
i'm a survivor however when we're
talking about the film the audience
didn't really appreciate the subtle
british humor and the film actually
failed at the box office despite the
fantastic script writing few people
actually remember this film now
therefore i bet in my small quiz most of
you probably chose option a war games
let's talk about that
indeed this film made hacking popular
and also a contemporary topic but let's
see how realistic the 1983 film really
is
this time the main character is a high
school student his name is david
lightman and at the beginning of the
film the young hacker uses a modem to
connect to the school's server and he
subsequently corrects a bad grade that
he had in biology
and again we are pretty much observing
social engineering david himself reveals
the method of hacking the system they
change the password every couple of
weeks but i know where they write it
down but is it true this phrase is still
somewhat relevant well many users store
passwords on a note glued to the monitor
i remember when i was a kid actually
there was this family computer right and
my mom actually left a note on the
family computer which claimed exactly
that function but let's get back to war
games here the system looks quite
realistic there are clear commands and
instructions on the screen the cursor
flashes where you can enter or change
information and this is actually what
similar systems look like in the early
80s the only inaccuracy here that i can
spot is that the modem connection
process happens way too fast but i think
this is acceptable for a feature film
right
protovision i have you now
now further along in the story david
tries to connect the computer of an
electronic game developer the young
hacker doesn't actually know the phone
number to which the modem of this
company is connected but he does know
the city the small california city of
sunnyvale and therefore he runs a
program that dials all of the phones in
the city in order with the help of such
a tool david manages to find a computer
connected to that network i need to say
this moment is also absolutely genuine
in the early 80s this technique was
called hammer or demon dialing and it
was used by the first ever network
hackers by the way after the release of
the film this technique was called war
dialing quite a suited name the next
part is also pretty plausible david
doesn't crack the password to the
computer head-on but he begins to
instead collect information about the
system in particular he learns the name
of the deceased son of the program's
creator he then tries that as a password
now this technique unsurprisingly is
still used today before starting a rough
search of all possible passwords hackers
collect information about the user often
the name of a favorite football team a
book or a cat is used as a password even
professional hackers can get caught out
because of this we even actually made a
video about this take a look if you
missed it but then the real sci-fi part
begins it turns out that this guy
uncovered the password to the computer
of the ministry of defense and almost
started world war iii let's play
global thermal nuclear war
fine
all right moreover a supercomputer with
artificial intelligence actually appears
in the film which understands questions
asked analyzes what is happening and
draws conclusions much like the function
of my quora account fortunately or
unfortunately even now such systems do
not exist computers and smartphones have
learned to pass simple voice queries but
they're still very very far from
understanding the meaning
hey alexa play heaven is a place on
earth by belinda carlisle
sorry i don't know that another thing
that's become really overused after the
recent war games is computers
[Music]
exploding from being overloaded now i
think
well this phenomenon has space operas to
thank specifically the old star treks
right i remember the computers on the
bridge of the enterprise sparkling and
smoking in almost every episode and i've
seen something similar in the old james
bond movies too but in films about
hackers explosive special effects
firstly appeared in war games now we've
also got another interesting question
here how realistic is the image of this
protagonist
well anyone could have taken pizzeristan
off for a veteran hacker right
but could children really be hackers of
government systems
the answer this question is very simple
in the year that war games was released
america was stirred up by the trial of
the members of hacker group 4-1-4
computer geniuses penetrated dozen
closed systems from security pacific
national bank to the national atomic
laboratory in los alamos but the real
hunt factors began when they hacked
memorial sloan-kettering cancer center
and accidentally deleted all of the
medical records of all patients
now the fbi specialists managed to track
down the phone numbers from which the
hacking was carried out all the numbers
began with the milwaukee regional code
414
within a few days all of these group
members were detained the leader of the
group tim winslow was only 20 years old
right the youngest neil patrick was 17.
you can go to jail for that only if
you're over 18.
now due to his age neil actually avoided
a prison sentence he decided to take
advantage of his position and actually
became a real media star over the next
year he appeared on the phil donahue
show the cover of newsweek and actually
as a cyber security expert he spoke at
congressional hearings neil's stories
were painfully reminiscent of war games
for example he claimed that often they
didn't even have to search for passwords
axis was granted just using default ones
like admin admin right and they found
unprotected computers through sequential
searching
now how did the authors of the film
manage to predict the appearance of
young hackers
well they had a good consultant peter
schwartz he was the teacher of the
stanford research institute who told the
creators of war games about this new
phenomenon but the film didn't just
expose this new subculture it actually
popularized it the owners of bulletin
board systems or bbs drew attention to a
significant increase in visits to these
proto-social networks specifically after
the release of the film young people
became more and more interested in
computer networks and they actually
began to buy modems and you know
lawmakers didn't stand aside by 1984 the
us congress actually included computer
fraud in the comprehensive crime control
act and in 1986 it was amended by the
computer fraud and abuse act the entire
system of counteracting cyber crime
still actually relies on those
modifications to the law
now it's unknown what had a greater
impact right was it the hype around
4-1-4 or was it the huge success of the
film war games but i do know for sure
that the film grossed more than 70
million dollars at the box office this
figure is actually higher than what
terminator would gross in the following
year
[Music]
and yes it was not by chance that i
remembered about the killer robots the
second part of the legendary franchise
gave us another vivid image of a hacker
the young and daring john connor was the
future leader of the human resistance he
actually had the dream of any teenager
an ultra compact atari portfolio
computer he was using it for very
dubious purposes hacking atms go baby go
baby go baby
all right
hey it worked
all right easy money right you know i
think the creators of the film did a
pretty good job on creating that
interface the program that figures out
pin codes it was pretty realistic also
it's important to note after the release
of the film more than one teenager was
combing through the network in search of
such devices but they were pretty
disappointed the device looked realistic
but it actually never existed in real
life just like the power loader from
another cameron movie the screenwriters
deliberately came to compromise with
reality the truth is that ping codes are
never stored and never have been stored
on bank cards via the magnetic stripe
when proceeding such a card the atm
sends its number and the pin code
entered by the user to the bank's
information system and then it waits for
authorization of course such systems
were initially protected from brute
force attacks if they received three to
six incorrect pin codes in a row the atm
received a command not to return the
card
therefore even if john connor had such
equipment he wouldn't have even been
able to withdraw the money rather he
would have probably gotten the stolen
credit card numbers on one of the
hackers bbs's and used them to pay
online so the scene with the money theft
was in certain films to demonstrate a
tool that would help the heroes with a
more important matter the destruction of
the chip with it john could open up the
cyberdyne system storage you've got to
agree that if john had used the method
of hacking from sneakers it would have
not turned out so spectacular okay
i'll give it a shot
however sneakers from 1992 was
remembered for a few more things this is
the first film in which one of the
characters was inspired by specific and
easily recognizable person behind the
image of owen whistler emery the famous
phone cracker joseph carl ingressia was
guest now from birth joseph was blind
and he had an absolutely musical ear
this feature helped a five-year-old boy
to hear what other people don't even pay
attention to
during phone calls high and quiet
signals can be heard through the handset
right
now joseph tried to imitate them with a
whistle
and after a couple of years he actually
picked up a melody that opened up access
to free long distance calling
the whistle mimicked the service signals
of the telephone company but this story
would only really appear in the late 60s
when joseph becoming a student at the
university of south florida began to let
his friends make phone calls to anywhere
in the world for just a dollar
friends would actually eventually come
up with this nickname whistler now a
large number of unpaid calls obviously
attracted the attention of the telephone
company and in 1968 joseph was arrested
by fbi agents whistler managed to get
off with a suspended sentence but
newspapers wrote a lot about his method
and a couple of years later a young
engineer john thomas draper managed to
create a device that operates on the
same principle with the help of a
whistle from a pack of cap and crunch
cornflakes draper actually created
what's known as a blue box a tool for
hacking telephone networks
two one two five
the simple device gave rise to a whole
movement of freakers from the words
freak and frequency it's actually funny
that apple's founders steve jobs and
steve wozniak also dabbled with this
technology only they replaced the
whistle with electronic components
however the apple story really deserves
its own video so we might do that in the
future let us know if you're interested
in that in the comments who else is
going to change the world marty
greenpeace
but anyway let's get back to the film
sneakers the film is also remembered for
the fact the approach to demonstrating
computer hacking on the screen has
changed for example when decrypting
files or connecting to a secure network
strange characters first appeared on the
screen and then they gradually turned
into the text of a graphical interface
now for the first time ever hacking a
computer system turned into a beautiful
site and the very next year we saw an
example of three-dimensional hacking
with jurassic park
so in the film the young heroine ariana
richards caused more than one smile with
her phrase
[Music]
i was also smiling when i heard this the
interface of the screen didn't look like
any of the unix shells that i knew but
when choosing the materials for this
video i realized that we were all
laughing at that girl in vain you know
the film actually showed an existing
three-dimensional graphical file manager
fsn3d this was actually an experimental
program for silicon graphics computers
it was these very computers that we used
to create the realistic models of the
dinosaurs that you see in the film and
also the metamorphoses of the liquid
robot from the terminator they were all
calculated on similar servers so the
famous film showed a real-life program
unfortunately it was never really
brought to a stable release but the
technology that was used in it is
probably used in your computer too the
opengl interface was licensed by
microsoft a few years later but the real
celebration of 3d interfaces came with
the movie hackers
[Music]
now this film is often scolded by people
who aren't familiar with the hacker
subculture of course even a layman
understands that the interfaces of
gibson supercomputers are more like a
model of a city and are extremely
non-functional the hacks look extremely
unrealistic as well and the hackers
themselves look more like street
hooligans than defcon visitors i don't
even want to comment on the actions of
viruses that ignore out files on
computer screens but to accuse the
authors of the film of being ignorant of
hacker culture well that doesn't really
have any grounding easter eggs and hints
for people familiar with the mata
scattered throughout the film the
hacking of telephone networks and this
time with the help of a dictaphone a
reference to the maurice worm a story
about a pool on the roof which refers to
the memoirs of alan shur and these were
real books to any professional in those
years the film also showcases the mass
arrests of suspected cyber criminals and
those were actually carried out by the
fbi between 1990 and 1991 there's even a
scene in the film where it actually
demonstrates what the real work of
hackers looks like long and tedious
hours of studying the source code
analyzing the system searching for
traces and vulnerabilities so this was
all done so the audience didn't fall
asleep and it had to be decorated with
abstract formulas and special effects
right
now hackers was the first film about
computer crimes and this shifted the
emphasis from authenticity
to entertainment for the first time
unfortunately the bet didn't really pay
off and the film failed miserably at the
box office but another blockbuster that
deliberately played with the concept of
reality managed to make a real hacker
program into a movie star
[Music]
i'd like to welcome to the stage the
matrix reloaded of 2003. now the
beginning of the second film of the cult
cyberpunk franchise trinity hacks the
city's power supply system using the
nmap program nmap effectively is utility
that scans any given range of addresses
within a computer network ideologically
this is really the same as the war dial
it's happening exactly as before
well not exactly
[Music]
the program sequentially sends requests
to the list of addresses and then
analyzes the responses now since
programs respond differently to some
requests nmap actually has this feature
that allows you to determine the type
and version of the operating system it
allows you to determine the network
programs used and make a list of various
equipment such as computers servers and
routers right and all this information
is very important for real hacking after
the premiere of matrix reloaded nmap
became almost as famous as the lead
actors themselves this tool for hackers
and system administrators began to
appear regularly in different hollywood
films from the born ultimatum to oceans
eight the authors of the program even
created a page dedicated to the
filmography of these subsequent films
and on the other hand the authenticity
of trinity's actions forced scotland
yard to issue a statement to the viewers
of the film the british police have
officially warned anyone that trying to
repeat what they saw is a criminal
offence perhaps they were afraid that
this episode would cause the same wave
of interest in hacking computer networks
as well war games did back in the 80s
[Applause]
now i couldn't let this video go without
mentioning q's big hack in skyfall this
is a movie that's likely to be fresh in
all of our minds and the scene is
honestly one of the most beautiful
things that i've ever seen on the telly
that is but really q mentioning security
through obscurity as if this is the most
elite thing that a hacker could ever do
well this is actually a phrase that
cyber security experts use to mock
security systems that well rely on the
principle that nobody can be bothered to
even hack them now security through
observation is actually notoriously
unreliable and all it does is render the
information that you're trying to hide
unreadable to humans you're fully able
to reverse the observation using a
program and the only thing that it does
is just adds the time it takes to hack
the system a good friend of mine
actually mentioned that this scene
replicates the ending to the book
digital fortress by dan brown pretty
much verbatim which is quite interesting
so look whether you ascribe to belief
that hacking nowadays looks like this
because it's beautiful and interesting
to the viewer or that the government is
trying to discourage would be hackers
it's clear that real methods don't
really feature much anymore in
mainstream media it was this story that
led me to the idea that many hollywood
companies deliberately choose to distort
real technologies in their films
for example if you remember hackers
right well in the finale of the film the
characters managed to get away by
hacking a traffic light control system
to arrange such a thing they wouldn't
even need a computer now a special
infrared transmitter would really be
enough these are still on many emergency
vehicles a person doesn't actually see
them work but the sensors mounted on
traffic lights reacts to their flashes
when the police or firefighters would
approach them the light automatically
then switches to green no more traffic
now of course this system isn't a secret
for real computer experts but ordinary
citizens shouldn't really know about it
therefore the real method of exploiting
the vulnerability of traffic lights was
hidden behind the scene of hacking a
computer system
[Music]
now you know similar thoughts actually
visited me when i watched this brilliant
series about cyber criminals it's called
mr robot now through this action huge
number of utilities and programs really
used by hackers appear in the frame
these heroes can be seen utilizing
special linux builds such as kali linux
right they crack passwords using john
the ripper and lore information using
crypto wall there are really no
meaningless interfaces found on screens
and the hacking scenes are most
reminiscent actually hot millions of
course adjusted for modern technology
people again are becoming really the
most vulnerable link right and more and
more attention is then being paid to
social engineering methods and this is
not surprising i mean real experts in
the field of computer security were
involved in the work on the film but
they also made some very interesting
mistakes here
you are going to modify the dad file
put
colby's terminal ip address in there
it's clear that technical consultants
know perfectly well that the number 373
cannot be in the ip address but this is
actually done specifically so the
viewers of the series don't flood the
real resource with requests uh for
exactly the same reason all phone
numbers you see in films will actually
start with a non-existent code by the
way some real ip addresses in the series
hide interesting sites easter eggs and
even network quests but in some moments
there are strange errors in inaccuracies
for example the main character often
works in the console with administrator
rights this is indicated by the root
system username at the same time he's
entering commands and complementing them
with sudo command now this command is
actually intended so that users with
limited rights can run some tasks on
behalf of users with more extensive
capabilities now this is a strange and
gross mistake i assume that it was
actually made intentionally so that
novice hackers couldn't actually repeat
what edis is doing by stupidly copying
his commands right
[Music]
in another quite realistic film black
hat 2015 there's this kind of built-in
vulnerability according to the plot the
hero of the film gets access to nsa
information by sending a trojan program
attached to a pdf document to one of the
employees right now the antivirus on the
mail server carelessly skips over this
dangerous attachment and the antivirus
on the victims computer
doesn't do anything to it either
now i really don't believe that the nsa
employs such unskilled system
administrators and careless employees
right it seems that the creators of the
movie have come to the point where
overly realistic descriptions of hacker
tools becomes so realistic that it
begins to pose actually a threat to
ordinary users and the last thing i'd
like to say on this topic if you're
going to shoot a video about hackers
don't try to defuse a nuclear bomb
through excel or start typing furiously
like the deadline for an essay on the
plausibility of plato's philosopher
rulers in 30 minutes with both hands
mashing the keyboard right this is not
how it works i'm trying it's moving too
fast
oh this is not good instead use the tool
that the most attentive of you would
have noticed in the video about the
mistakes of famous hackers do you know
what i'm talking about we'll take a
closer look at that laptop screen which
is in the cage something interesting is
happening on it can you see similar to a
kind of csi style hack
the site that is open on that page is
actually geektyper.com which simulates
hacking you can press any keys right the
fairly realistic code will then appear
on the screen so if you want to be known
as a cool hacker
use it in good health
anyway that's it for me today guys
thanks for joining me on another
jam-packed jimping jovial adventure into
the inland jungle and i will see you in
the next video
[Music]
you